hi everyone and thank you for joining us
today and a very warm welcome to the
studio sml online talk how to survive as
a small design studio in singapore this
event is presented by the press room and
is supported by the design singapore
council and the national design center
i'm felicia from the design singapore
console and i will be your mc for today
so today's session how to survive as a
small design studio in singapore is the
first talk organized by studio sml a
website and podcast channel by the press
room that seeks to archive in-depth
stories of designers and their journeys
featuring design studios of various
sizes today's session will explore how
science could affect a studio's culture
and the projects that they do
so if that is my absolute pleasure to
present our speakers for today first up
we have gabriel tan creative director
and founder of gabrotan studio a design
practice that works at cultural
intersections gabriel is also the
creative director of interior design
studio antimatter singapore door handle
brand turn japanese furniture brand
aryake and portuguese craft brand origin
his works have won awards like the
industrial designer society of america's
idea award japan good design award and
the president's design award 2010.
following which we have jessica wong and
pamela ting co-founders of xinxiang
xinjiang is a contemporary furniture
homeware and lifestyle label based in
singapore with roots firmly planted in
asian heritage
their concepts have earned various
honours at the singapore creator awards
2019 asean furniture design competition
2018 and the 2016 international
furniture affairs singapore design stars
and next up we have randy chan principal
architect and founder of zark
collaboratives
randy's architectural and design
experience crosses multiple fields and
skills and is guided by the simple
philosophy that architecture and
aesthetics are part of the same impulse
these projects have received accolades
like the singapore institute of
architects gold medal for 38 holland
park in 2010 and the president's design
award design of the year 2012 for his
collaborative artwork building as a body
and last but not least we have xin boon
yang co-founder of eco-eat architects
ecowit is a multidisciplinary practice
with a modern and progressive approach
to design with an emphasis on balancing
aesthetics with rigor and program with
budget the studio has won awards at
various ceremonies like the 2015 world
architecture festival and the
president's design award design of the
year 2008.
without further ado i would now be
passing the time over to kelly chang our
moderator for today to officially open
the session kelly is the brains behind
studio sml and the creative director and
founder of the press room a publishing
and design consultancy she has served as
a jungle lecturer in singapore
universities and has set on
international design judging panels such
as the raid.awards design for asia award
creative circle award and james tyson
award kelly was also recently named
designer of the year at the 2020
president's design award so kelly over
to you please
thanks alicia
okay uh hi guys uh thank you for joining
this first top series of studio xml so i
want to share a little bit about the
inspiration behind starting this
self-initiated project
i think for the past 20 years i've been
an editor of magazine and kind of
unknowingly i realized that i've been
documenting the design scene in
singapore
and uh in the last few years you know i
it was quite funny because i got a lot
of requests people asking like oh you
know can i you know can you send me that
article that you published the other
time can you uh is it okay we use this
picture from the magazine and so on and
so forth and i realized that i have such
a huge archive of
uh stories and materials of local
designers but i think the one that that
really triggered me to to act on this
idea of studio xml was uh two years ago
when
one of our master architect terry hill
passed passed away
i realized that i held on to one of his
last interviews which i did for
singapore architect and uh with the
interview i actually requested for uh
carrie to do a self sketch which he
happily obliged because he loves to draw
actually
so um when he passed on uh his family
and his studio
uh start to ask me for the sketch
because none of them archived it you
know and uh the other the other thing is
so after today some of the developers
who are you know um
uh developed uh who had carrie hill as
the architect are still asking me for
the sketch
so it it just made me realize how
important uh archiver is
and also that i think since uh since the
independence of singapore i think
currently we are seeing sort of like the
fifth sixth generation of architects
architecture being one of the oldest
discipline in singapore uh we have boone
today who is i think a fourth generation
randy is the fifth generation and then
now currently we already have the sixth
generation of architects practicing
we have already lost the stories of the
first second generation sure they are
you know some of their works are
archived and uh their stories may be
archived in a more academic way and all
that yeah so i always remember the fact
that it's not uh why is there not uh
such a platform that kind of share these
uh stories of designers from singapore
you know uh we
we need to archive this so that we can
start to have a design legacy and we're
already losing our first second
generation of architects and all that
some of the design disciplines such as
product design graphic design session
design are relatively uh young and new
so i think we should start now so that
we can
document them from the beginning so it
was really with that uh with that kind
of uh simple aspiration to to document
uh stories of singapore designers so
that we can build up a design history
archive and from there my dream is that
a design culture for singapore can
evolved uh yeah so that is the the
aspiration that i have for studio xml
and um so the the intent for studio xml
is really to to entertain and to educate
at the same time i hope that this
platform can bridge the distance between
entertainment and design
to reach out to a bigger audience beyond
just the design community
that's why i decided to start a website
instead of having a book or whatever
anyway you know we need this to be an
ongoing thing so the website is the best
platform people can read when they're
free and all that it's free for all
anybody can read it not just from
singapore people from abroad globally
can also uh learn about the stories of
singapore designers which i think would
be really great also in promoting
singapore design
um so that's why i wanted to do this
project on uh on a website and also that
uh we actually have a podcast alongside
this website because i think that the
podcast uh platform is a new frontier uh
people are getting so busy and so lazy
these days you know they watching a
three minute video is too long for them
one minute also too long you know so uh
podcast is very good because people can
be doing their things and they can
listen in the background people can be
driving and they can be listened and all
that so uh this project to me is also
very fun in some way because it is the
first time that our studio the press
room produced a podcast and uh with the
help of my team you know all of us are
first timers in producing a podcast but
but we were so hands-on we we designed
the audio branding we did the jungle we
did editing we did everything on
ourselves you know within the studio and
and i'm very uh very very proud of the
outcome and very happy that the the team
actually everybody wrote their lease
lease and help with this website and
podcast
the third reason why i'm doing studio
xml is that uh it is also actually a
study
of design studios and how they grow
um some studios are one-man show some
are small some are medium-sized and and
some grow exponentially and become big
studios
um and as a person who has run studios
for for 20 years it you know it's it's
very uh it's very fascinating for me you
know is it by choice is it by luck is it
how you know how do some studios grow so
big and then some decide to be small and
all that um i i think that there is not
a very clear science behind this because
every
architect every designer uh kind of like
we're not trained in business so we
can't run it organically and all that
and uh this is why uh in the launch
exhibition for single xml i call all the
design studios abstract creatures
because we just survived in a kind of a
very weird way on
ourselves
and um lastly i just want to
talk a little bit about this talk series
um it i hope that this talk series can
can carry on beyond covet
because
i think that it is important for us to
have this kind of sort of informal
symposiums uh very much like salon style
kind of a talk session that you know
provides a platform for the design
community to talk about uh you know
sometimes issues in the industry or to
talk about difficult uh topics you know
uh in a very informal setting so that we
can all share and kind of uh come
together you know to see how this uh can
work out and i think this uh this kind
of uh culture is very common with uh
actually the third generation architects
like william lim and tankwand
uh william is known for his uh sort of
living room salon style uh talks you
know and a lot of these conferences are
born out of this uh very very informal
talks and uh tango be used to invite
students and architects to his studio
you know to share and get projector to
give us free beer and all that and uh i
really miss the
uh this kind of bonding you know with
with the design industry and i hope that
still sml can provide this platform for
uh for the older designers and
architects like uh like us we can
provide the platform and the younger
people can come forward and you know
share stories with us and you know learn
from us in some ways and uh in better
times when uh covert is over uh i really
hope that still sml talk series can take
on a kind of a pop culture dna because
talking about design talking about
architecture doesn't have to be
difficult and unenjoyable i think it can
be accessible and make understandable to
the people
over a glass of beer over a glass of
wine so in better times i think that
hopefully we can hold these stocks in a
bar in a club and uh and we can all have
our wine in hand and
and
design council has agreed give me some
pocket money by you so uh we're really
looking forward to the day where
students ml talk series uh can provide
this platform for the community to come
together uh to share
both uh our sort of uh stories and uh
hardships issues whatever uh so that the
the design community community can grow
and we can have a healthier uh design
ecosystem
and uh okay so lastly um i feel that
this uh this project uh for me
personally uh has a certain sense of
urgency because i i i think hopefully i
have a good 20 years to go um and uh i i
don't know how much time i have to
document people so i have to do it quite
fast um
and
so i i thank
all of you who
agreed to come in the inaugural issue
xml i thank design council
for supporting this project for
believing in it and i hope that for the
people who are listening to this uh
this talk uh please come forth if you
want to offer some kind of help because
this is a completely self-initiated
self-funded project uh i
it's not for myself i hope that we can
have this archive 20 years later this
will be so invaluable
for the whole design community as an
education archive uh and as a legacy for
the design industry and for designers so
uh yes so for those who are interested
to to you know help
in this project please get in touch with
me okay so uh that's uh in a nutshell
what studio sml is about uh
i am now going to pass on to our first
speaker of the day
gabriel thanh who will share with us
about his practice
thanks kelly
yeah it's a pleasure for me to to share
with you today and thank you very much
for designing singapore and studio sml
for inviting
um
let me just share my screen here
so yeah for for those of you who may not
know what i do
i'm currently based in singapore and
portugal
myself right now i'm in portugal i moved
here about a year ago to start a
portuguese studio
and
my studio works in the field of interior
design
with the brand studio antimatter uh
furniture and lighting design with
gabriel tan studio and origin which is a
brand i started over here in portugal
which focuses on craft collaborations
with portuguese craftsmen but could also
in the future involve craftsmen of other
countries
so
for studio antimatter we we do interior
design for
for both private clients and developers
right now we are also moving into
some small hospitality projects
so these are
our approach generally to
interior design is that we we try to
bespoke design as much
as possible the whole space including
the furniture and sometimes even the
objects
so for example for this marina one show
flat
other than the lamp and the sofa
and the carpet everything else was was
designed by us the outdoor chair
uh was made in singapore with a with a
metal work craftsman
the
the wooden console was made in malaysia
with one of the factories we know very
well and we actually made the coffee
tables in japan because we couldn't find
a metal spinning in singapore so
we got a japanese craftsman to to make
the coffee tables
and
yeah i mean this is another
penthouse interior that we did
you know with with our objects from
origin made in portugal
chess from japan that that we designed
for aryake
so i would say when we work in spaces we
think very much about how
objects furniture and space combine
harmoniously
and we also try if if we do source for
furniture we try to bring in brands that
are not available in singapore like like
this uh coffee table from carl anderson
which is a small
swedish brand uh that is they don't
export very much outside of europe here
yeah so here are some some more images
of recent interior works we have done
and then a large part of my presentation
will be talking about furniture and my
experiences with with different cultures
because i kind of view myself as a bit
of a cultural nomad
[Music]
partly because
i think in singapore
currently we are going through like a
bit of a craft renaissance i mean there
are a lot of urban craftsmen that are
self-taught uh but i i think when when i
started getting into design like more
than 10 years ago
there was
very little of this movement and i was
very interested to explore craft
cultures of of different countries so
furnishing utopia is a project that i
was involved in in the u.s
it started because i was teaching at the
university of oregon in 2012 and 2015
and one of my my fellow professors was
doing research into the shakers so i
followed him
one one winter after my my teaching
stint ended to to the sheikah villages
in hancock
and i saw that uh what they were doing
there i mean they preserved all the all
the sheikah artifacts from the the 19th
century
so we could actually have access to all
these beautiful handmade furniture
by this utopian community that existed
from the 1800s
and this i mean for for those of you who
know the shakers furniture influence a
lot of
contemporary furniture designers from
beau morgan in denmark to japanese
design as well you can find shaker
chairs even in japan
being made today
and
we decided uh me and some american
colleagues to to start a project to
gather a group of of designers from all
over the world uh to reinterpret shaker
furniture and to create a kind of new
shaker movement or a new movement
inspired by the shakers
so it was a it was a collective and we
started to to design new products uh
inspired by this philosophy of uh beauty
and utility uh being going hand in hand
it's a bit different from like you know
the bar house or or functionalism where
instead of form fellows function the
shakers believed in
making things both utilitarian and
beautiful at the same time
that beauty was also in some way a
very important
and for for people who you who you know
basically build their own furniture and
and create
uh everything that they need uh just for
themselves i think that was
something very interesting uh and they
believe in like worshipping i mean they
were christian um
christian communities so they believed
in worshiping by
doing uh good work with their hands
uh praying by basically building
furniture in the workshop which
kind of blew my mind i never thought you
could pray by making furniture but in
some way that was their their ritual of
of making good things uh with their
hands and in that way uh honoring uh
god yeah
myself i'm not super religious but
i saw it as something really poetic and
beautiful so they invented a lot of
technologies as well uh cheese presses
uh butter presses the flat broom uh they
claim to have invented it because before
the brooms were cylindrical and they
found that it was much more functional
to press the brooms into
into a
flat object so that you could use it to
clean more easily
and we had we had access to the archives
of like 300 over different designs
their chairs are the most well known but
they they created a lot of other things
as well and then these are the products
that we design uh eventually and we
photographed them in the shaker village
and we exhibited them in new york in
stockholm in chicago
over a period of
three years
so these are some of the items i
designed for this exhibition
a bench
that is basically a kind of
reinterpretation of the shaker bench but
with
with some new details in joinery
a stool a kind of carry stool with a
handle
based on the idea of utility and
mobility
a door stopper
which is now being produced by a german
company authentics
so it's it's kind of inspired by some of
their turn knobs of of their
of the objects that they use
the kitchen objects and how i felt that
this was a very nice handle that you
could use as a door stopper with a
granite base
and also like a bedside table with a
hidden secret compartment so basically
very simple utilitarian furniture but
with focus on the details
um was my interpretation of what
shaker furniture was and i tried to
bring that into my own work
yeah
and eventually some of the pieces ended
up with brands like these two uh from
swedish brand blast station saw it in
the stockholm exhibition that we did
and decided to produce it and this was
like a basic a new take on the shaker
chair
where
you could hang this on the wall it's a
it's a three-legged stool chair typology
it's super compact and super small
and this is photographed in the shaker
village and the inspiration actually was
from the shaker stove that you see on
the bottom left
so
combining the idea of of a stove
using the shape to
to redesign it uh
for a new type of shaker chair
yeah and the the other the next project
i'm talking about is is something i
started in japan uh called aryake
so iraqi was is a project that
initiated because i met these two
japanese factories lagna tech
which is
a company in kyushu producing furniture
they have 50 employees
they were making furniture like these uh
basically life edge wooden slabs
country style i would say like modern
country style japanese furniture
and then there was another company here
at the chair which is the two founders
are good friends uh and this is the
furniture that here at the chair makes
so they they approached me with the view
of designing some new products for them
because they were exhibiting at the
singapore financial affair and they
wanted the collection that was targeted
at the singapore market
so i visited their factory in in kyushu
in southern japan and uh
sagar prefecture which is like the
ceramic province
and i realized that
they have very good craft they have you
know five axis cnc machines both
technology and handbook they have
everything to to be a
a very uh
progressive brand but the thing that
they like was was design and designers
uh they were mainly designing everything
in-house or working with some
uh
older
local japanese designers
which which was very relevant to the
local market but i felt that
maybe they needed some some intervention
to help them to internationalize and i i
advise them to
instead of looking at just singapore uh
why not look at the world as a global
marketplace because if you if you
present your works uh you know in milan
fair or in stockholm fair you will be
able to reach the buyers
in singapore as well
and also be able to reach buyers in
tokyo because
their products were not even selling
so much in in tokyo or osaka they were
mainly selling in the south
so
i convinced them to to do a bigger
project so they said okay like could you
work with our annual budget we have a
small annual budget
if you're willing to work with a small
budget
what is the best way for it and
so i use the budget to
to invite designers to to come to japan
so the beginning it was just
three designers i invited uh
a japanese architect from tokyo
and the sun and vol which is a norwegian
design duo that i i respect very much
and staffan home a swedish designer who
used to be a trained carpenter
and eventually we also invited
non-architects from denmark
and other designers to join the project
and and we designed new furniture for
them and
the interesting thing about this process
was that we we all went to japan always
at the same time the designers and
myself as the creative director
uh normally i think when brands do
product development they invite the
designers one by one to their factories
but for me i felt that there was energy
and
synergy when everybody is there
at the same time because we could all
contribute to
looking at each other's designs
synchronizing them making sure that
whatever i design is
not
clashing with another designer's work
and you know like this image pretty sums
up the the process where uh one of the
designers gets stuck and another
designer would sketch a detail uh to to
try to help the other designer out uh
while we are prototyping so it was a i
mean each designer was
uh we all have our own clients we all
have our own body of work that uh
but uh at the same time it was a very no
ego process you know uh
helping each other out sketching over
each other's sketches at the end we
signed the products under our own names
but then i would say there's always a
little bit of stuff on or a little bit
of kg or a little bit of norm in my work
as well because we were critiquing each
other's work at the same table not say
critiquing but more like
helping each other out in some way or
the other
so
these are some of the the prototypes we
made while over there
uh
and some of the photography that we did
and yeah we we also had a graphic
designer and a photographer there uh
from switzerland that that i invited and
they were working on the branding the
graphic design at the same time as us
working on the product so
uh when we went for the first workshop
actually the
the brand didn't even have a name yet
and we were voting for the name we were
voting for which was the best logo the
best brand color so the product
designers could also get involved with
that together with the brand owners
uh instead of
you know the basically the the branding
and corporate identity was built at the
same time
as the products
and we made like mock-ups with mdfs with
the help of the craftsman with plywood
and these are the eventual products i
mean of course we had to go through many
rounds of prototyping even after the
designers left japan but you know from
the first prototype of this uh
to the final table you can see that it
was it was not a very big difference and
having the one is the one models within
uh one week really helped to speed up
the the process
and yeah here's other like images of
rough models that were made during the
the one week workshop
uh you know sketching over
with with a marker making changes and
eventually this is the final product
so i think the
as much as design is about you know
of course a lot of it is working with
computers working with technology but
uh this human interaction you know with
the craftsman conversations uh being
together in one place
uh like what was kelly is uh mentioning
as well you know
the human interaction is really a large
part of the process for me and bringing
people together uh to work on projects
together is something i i strongly
believe in which
unfortunately was a bit lost during this
pandemic where we had to do a lot of
product development remotely
and these are some of the
other products that were mock-ups and
final products that were made
so i think ariaki was was a very special
brand in that sense because
as a japanese brand we tried to make it
very progressive and very uh
forward-looking as a and not so
conservative
and we during the workshops we we also
came up with
uh interesting finishing solutions such
as using indigo dye which normally
uh
is not so widely used on wood furniture
to use it as part of the aryaka
furniture pallet so we introduce indigo
wood
instead of
you know instead of the normal new
nordic pastel colors that all the brands
are using we wanted to use colors
inspired by japan so
the black is actually
from sumi inc
which is japanese calligraphic ink we
use it to we use it to apply it on the
furniture and and indigo so these were
the two colors that we introduced black
and blue
but using traditional japanese dyes and
materials
and eventually the the collection we
showed it is stockholm design week so
our strategy was to enter scandinavia
um
as the first port of call uh because
there is a lot of mutual respect and
aesthetics sensibilities shared between
scandinavia and japan so we showed
the first year in stockholm design week
in an apartment that was basically due
for renovation and we managed to get
this space for almost nothing
because the
the owner was
was a friend of a mutual friend and we
really didn't have budget to show in in
the trade fair
so we we removed all the rubble and
rubbish from this construction site and
we clean it out and we we use it for for
an exhibition and it became
kind of a sensation because it was like
a private exhibition with no published
address on the internet so only if you
received the email you would be you will
know the location of of the show
and uh but in the end we had i would say
three or four hundred people that that
managed to find this space and came to
the event and
uh there were many i mean pictures are
still being reposted today online
of for this exhibition
and we named the exhibition a quiet
reflection
and yeah it wouldn't have been possible
without some very passionate
collaborators like hana nova which was
the
editor of residence magazine at that
time
because she heard that we were looking
for a location and we
we didn't have much budget but she
really liked the brand
so she offered to help
connect us with with the owner of this
apartment that she knew was
was really not not using the apartment
and uh
subsequently the next year we showed in
another venue a bigger venue which was a
church so this was like a church right
in the middle of the city in stockholm
uh
for the african uh immigrant community
so it was also a church that not many
local people have visited
they were doing like
gospel singing like harlem style type of
gospel singing and you know um
they have also uh
so-called homeless dinners being uh this
is what this space is normally used for
where they serve the homeless people the
food and we we went to ask them if we
could rent this space for a design
exhibition and
uh they were a bit shocked at first that
somebody wanted to do this in this space
but it was really historic and beautiful
space and
and um we had also a very a very good
show there with with lots of good images
and then in the third year uh
where the brand finally i would say we
we grew up we we had a bit more bigger
budgets now and we rented a national
archive for the exhibition which is a
well-known uh
a well-known building in stockholm
it used to be the
national archive where they keep all the
records of the citizens
and now it's used as a kind of webbing
space or event space
and
it was like 500 square meters
and yeah we did our last exhibition here
right before the pandemic in february of
last year
so yeah i mean watching this brand grow
over the last four years
has been
a pretty amazing journey for myself i
also grew along with the brand i would
say my confidence
in dealing with
with well-known designers and also
dealing with retailers dealing with
distributors
uh getting to know every part of the
industry
and yeah the the last two projects i'm
talking about is turn is is a door
handle company it's a startup company
from singapore that i helped to to
creative direct and
to invite designers to join
so
they developed this slow rebound
technology
that is the first in the world where you
actually depress the lever door handle
and it rebounds silently and slowly so i
invited
different designers to contribute
to their to the
um to their portfolio so it's not just
about the technology but also about a
sculptural and minimal door handle and
this brand is right now in in still in
prototyping stages but they're about to
launch i would say in the next six
months the products will be ready for
for sale
and we got good designers like
good architects like mk 27 and
[Music]
snohetta to design door handles for them
and
surprisingly it was not so difficult to
get them to agree because
i think for
for architects or designers when you
have a
interesting technology behind it it
doesn't really matter whether you're a
startup or a known company
but if they see the potential in it i
think people would invest their time
to design products for it
and then after i moved to actually this
started this project started when i was
in the process of moving to portugal
uh yeah so this is a cork acoustic
panels made in portugal that using
recycled wine stoppers
which is now produced by the swedish
brand abstractor so i connected them
with with this factory that is doing
injection molded of cork
and the three of us collaborated to to
make these products
and the last project is my my own brand
that i started here origin
which
working with local craftsmen we we
started a brand here that is inviting
international designers myself designing
some of the pieces but also
working with international
designers that i know
to each work with different craftsmen
to create contemporary objects using a
traditional portuguese craft
so these are the pieces that i design
with a black terracotta from portugal a
very traditional technique over here
and
using it to reinterpret what is the
shape of a vase or challenging what is
the archetype of a vase yeah and we give
a lot of attention to the craftsman in
our branding and in our catalogs
because we feel that sometimes the
designer is being over promoted
so we want to promote the craftsman
instead and or for each product
there is both the name of the designer
as well as the craftsman
so it's kind of shared credits because
without the craft spender the products
can never be be realized yet and these
are some basically some images of of all
the products shot together
yeah and that's that's all i have for
you guys today thank you
[Music]
thank you for the time and yeah
thank you so much gabriel for your
sharing so now let us welcome jessica
wong and pamela ting co-founders of
shinshank on screen please
hello
hi
can you see us okay uh okay so we're
from
and um
actually is a play on the word scene
challenge
so
uh appreciation it means but we also
played on the chinese squad to be new
appreciation and the essence of the
brand is really to
be inspired by culture tradition
heritage and adding our own design
language and interpretation
in a contemporary way
so we find that a lot of um
chinese furniture well i say chinese
because we are ethnically chinese but
across asia encompasses a lot
a lot larger
in terms of race and cultures and
everything but we start from from you
know the chinese culture because we're
both chinese and i think that um when we
look at furniture from
from the chinese culture it's really
large and quite intimidating
so what we're trying to do um
china is to
to add our own voice to it that is you
know a lot more contemporary and modern
and being from singapore
um it also forces us to be a lot more
efficient in the use of space
um and also you know like changing homes
and everything which we'll talk about
later
uh so a little bit about our background
we met in jc which is like half our
lives away
um
and
i think back then we were not so close
until we both did an internship in
university
uh
in uh shanghai and china was very
inspiring for us because it had the
melting of the east and west and also
the old and the new
and um
i think they made us question our
identity as singaporeans as chinese
singaporeans and what it meant um to to
have this culture and a lot of the
culture that we learn in our homes uh is
very diluted from our ancestors
who came from china so some of the
things we recognized some we didn't and
i think that made us very curious to
understand like emblem symbols
shapes and everything
in design
so
we shared a flag together and then you
know along the way we started buying
pieces of furniture
decking up the space and i think that
kind of led us into
um we came back in 2014.
we didn't keep it quite early but we
both
went on to do our own
uh i mean i did interior graphic design
and pam worked in a thing
and i think that we always felt this
calming uh to address some that the
interest that was picked uh when we went
to shanghai and i think after five years
of working in our respective jobs
reasons step out and create his own
brand uh to design the homeware and for
the children so
actually yeah my background is actually
an architecture
but we thought that okay what can we use
these experiences to create a unique
selling point uh to take our stories and
our stories which were also similar to
what we saw that people around us wanted
like for example my interior design
clients they were seeking for pieces of
furniture that
referenced
like our
cultural heritage but yet had a
contractor touched it so i think that
was why we wanted to create a brand
and here we are today
from
a two i mean they took from just the two
of us in a small uh space in a small
room yeah i think we started in a room
in china right and like we were
literally like spraying things styling
things
and then slowly we moved on to our um
space in in chai which was a little bit
bigger and now we just need to our new
space which is six thousand square feet
so i guess the progression of it over
the last seven years seven years um it's
quite i mean i won't say it was very
exponential but um you can see that you
know it's it's baby steps and um of
course there were a lot of um
you know like chinese
yeah so i think um
at the end of the day we really want to
design pieces that speak to each
individual and i find that you know the
stories and
the experiences we have culturally
cannot be too different because you know
we're all here in
singapore in
asia and some of these elements that we
picked out for example
you know like listening to grandma in
her in her armchair sitting on a rocking
school
uh having dinner on a marble table like
all these are nostalgic elements that we
want to you know inject into the pieces
that we create without it looking too
like
to say something of the place that we're
in which is singapore that you know has
that mix as well
so
i guess that is still the the ethos and
essence that we come from everything
that we design
uh and we put forth um even in
collaborations that we do with other
people
yeah okay the next slide
okay okay so i think we already briefly
shared um
uh
about the brand so i think these are
just the three key points that we always
come back to to remind us why uh why we
are seeing china and why research
so
the first one would just be that our
homes are changing like the spaces we
live in are different the people i mean
the family sizes and all that the way we
use the space is also different
we need to illustrate on the next slide
okay for example like you can see home
settings smaller we see a dual uh people
wanting
more users for a piece of furniture so
for example this was actually
an interior design project that i did
way before sunshine and i really found
that people wanted to have flexibility
in the furniture and modularity to
address the different space
and when for example like this was
actually designed for a home for a
mother and doctor
i mean the doctor is an
adult working
baby and
just the two of them will be having
dinner at home but they will also have
guests come over on birthdays
chinese new year christmas whatever
and they would require the space to
allow dining for more people so we
actually designed this static cable to
become a
modular piece that could join with the
dining table
so we found it people yeah wanted this
flexibility
uh so the next point
um
yeah yeah so we don't stay in the same
house i mean i don't know how many of
you have actually stayed in the house
that you're born into but
my experiences i've moved more than 20
times in my lifetime and i'm not
super old so
um
yeah and i think it's because you know
we just need i don't know it's just a
you know change of space environment
we can see the next slide and
um
you know you move from your parents
place and then maybe you get married
move to a different place and then you
have children
so like you don't stay in the same house
for 10
more than 10 years and therefore the
furniture that we design is conscious of
that yeah what happens to the difference
like when you move forward
is it too big to bring the longer or
what happens
i mean those are just questions we
wanted to address in our designs yeah
and it was i mean it was a personal
experience when we moved to shanghai we
were like oh my god so many things to to
pack and like what do we do with all
this furniture if only we could
literally have them in modular
pieces and bring them
so the third one is the layer of culture
i think at home the focus where we first
learn about culture like expensive
stories from
from your grandparents from your parents
and all that we find that this
to us especially is that this piece of
culture is very important in defining
ourselves and makes us who we are
so
let's go on to the next slide
yeah
so we are like the stories the food
and how that furniture comes into this
role uh where we learn about ourselves
at home
so
next slide please so one of the first
pieces that we designed was the system
which is a three-part system so there is
the pan which is the top tray
which is the drawer and then the thumb
which is the stool
and
we made this basically conscious of the
fact that
as you wish
in colors that you wish and you can take
them apart as a poem also the elements
of you know asian and chinese it's it's
um in little things like the eaves and
um
the ears of the plants so you can make
it as chinese as you want and you can
make it as modern and i think that
encapsulates what we stand for as a
brand
um to still have the culture and
cultural element in it but
um allowing you know others to
personalize it
yeah
the next
so the next piece or so is something
like a bit more of a
more fun object because we did a project
and we spoke with people to ask them
what
kind
what would
make them want to keep a piece of
furniture forever and we knew that
from the stories is that through their
interactions and we also uncovered that
uh possibly
that you when you interact with
something like uh and you form that that
relationship as a child that was a very
strong emotional response that could
make you want to keep a piece of
furniture together
we wanted to capture that that
experience of um
having an approachable piece of religion
that something's not scary like for
example just now ken mentioned about
like traditional furniture being like
big and bulky and scary it could be
and she said that like she was very
scared of all parents antique furniture
and all that although they were so
beautiful but the piece that she loved
was something that she could play with
uh it had
it was a wash basin stand and it was
just the right height for our child to
to play and make believe and we wanted
to create uh that in our furniture
design so as i always tell people like i
love it like when i see this piece um
when i see people coming up to this
piece of furniture the smoking school um
you see people come coming to sit down
with like a like a rocking horse or they
could sit on me like normal chair
a bit more
not a little more shy and then i even
had like this grandfather came into a
store and he went live on the rocking
stool on his stomach and he flew like a
superman he told his grandson like uh
hey this is how you sit on it so i think
like you want to create that element of
like evil interaction and fun and like
emotional bonds with the furniture
so
bringing on to the last keys
so the last piece this one was our most
recent uh
winner which is the shared cable
uh i think for this piece uh it's
actually i mean you could go to our
website and find out more information to
see uh the photos or videos but
basically this is uh it's a folding
cable uh because we were thinking about
like what is the center of a foam in
in a lot of homes i mean there's always
this like folding table that could be
used for a lot of different things like
food
so we wanted to create this really
beautiful piece that uh
this piece is currently actually
entirely handcrafted in singapore also
because of like some kobe concerns
i mean currently travel it's much more
um
yeah so this piece can flow to a console
it still looks beautiful you still want
to put it in your house uh you can fold
down one flap and it becomes a triangle
so you can have a three person
game or like put it in the corner or you
can open it up fully but i think we just
really want to celebrate like the people
that we work with i think this name this
is made with a guy who's like in the 70s
and he has a lot of experience and all
that um
i mean
initially he started he would be the
kind would be a bit reluctant to work
with you because you still didn't know
you were proven yet but i think you're
so happy nowadays like whenever we go
and uh pick up the pieces like uh this
piece is really very beautiful you know
like uh my name is asking me to send it
to him that kind of stuff and
so yeah i think that's what we have to
share i mean yeah so if you're
interested to find out more on the
website
yeah and that's it thank you jessica and
pamela
welcome randy chan principal architect
and founder of collaborative screen
please
hi
hi hello everybody uh thank you kelly
and uh design singapore and
felicia
thank you for you're going to flash your
slide for me
so i shall begin in hokkien
how to tan in singapore that is the
value proposition i guess uh
in today's session
uh for those who who doesn't understand
hokkien uh tanja is how to survive
and i think today i just present just a
part of me right which is very much uh
i mean you saw on the left side anyway
this was uh part of the singapore
architects our journal uh artists
architect
curator
so um it's a kind of three in one and
and and today
the value proposition i guess um
uh in the light of postcode and also the
fact that we have the 20
uh september 11th um uh anniversary of
this world trade center right
the practice actually was born out in
2001 so the question here was really
as i reflect right next slide please
the question here was really about
how
when do you really start a practice is
it a good time or bad times and and and
in the
series of slide i just want to
illustrate that
really um
it has been a journey for me in terms of
um
how it has evolved and and in terms of
as a belief in terms of um what design
is uh it has been a learning journey and
and as we speak of course what is this
postcode
scenario that's painted uh today will
not be the topic but it was more in
terms of what is
what has been uh the last 20 years for
me next
so uh you picture this is that this was
actually a a presentation that we we
liken the fact that uh we jump from room
to room okay almost like a butterfly but
i just like my practice to a just heart
store all right you you you actually can
cook many things whether you are
you know a chicken rice and specialize
and be good at it or you can actually
you know
have many dishes so i always tell them
that my practice you know as a
multi-disciplinary firm
uh which is very much how the world have
kind of panned out luckily
um back then 20 years ago um
uh i would say
an architect um that the whole scene
wasn't that
that close um the scene in the night in
the in the late 90s for singapore was
really
uh is still a formative year and thank
god
i would say that
design is converging and i'm glad that
we were in the right place at right time
and this is really illustrate how as a
mind map how we
i see the world uh in terms of
as much as this frame within the boxes
like next
and i just wanted to share that bit of
that compound memory uh for those who
are
born i mean uh who happened to to been
to this building night and day
uh one a common thing that when we have
a practice right after some time in
singapore is that you you always tend to
say that it's boring
it's um we don't have a culture
of design and so on and so forth
so um
um i just want to share that this was
where um i would say that it's one a
very key milestone to the practice of
zarch um this is actually a lagy road
uh it is uh uh we occupy the whole
entire floor and kelly was such a hub
flaw
we felt that if you know we are
practicing in singapore if the sin is so
dead flat boring right
um one the thing about the practices was
that you want to be multi-disciplinary
you want to effect a change in terms of
um how the design scene is at the same
time you're running a business so how do
you do that next please
so we thought that huh we must have
collaboration okay so what does it mean
so um again i i i better land
accreditation uh this is also uh
the time where kelly is um the sa
uh
editor collaboration was kind of
important um whatever that means i shall
illustrate it
in
in the in the later part of of of some
of the projects next
and we thought that ha we must have a
bar to practice to survive to tan chat
to know people
what's a better way to have a bar we
attract all the creative to come
so we have a bar at this second level
and going up the staircase you can see
the graffiti right it can't reach the
middle kingdom like that's where such is
and then kelly is right at the top where
we also have next place
we have a gallery and and this gallery
actually were home to the illustrative
art so we thought that in a practice in
singapore right i think what a key thing
what that was very formative was
we are so small by right we should know
everybody right but we often we often
are in silos because
maybe perhaps design is kind of a
secretive thing we we need to kind of
you know be away from everybody and do
our own work
um so the idea of collaboration the idea
of creating a space for that i think was
a very important ingredient to say
to come back to this value proposition
how to survive as a small practice you
need a community i think that is very
important for me and in fact it was a
seven years project it was a very
fulfilling project of course you have
many booths you have also meet
many creative from
other fields not just architects i mean
we have uh wonderful sessions you know
uh whether it's illustrative art whether
it's graphic artist whether you have
stand-up comedy whether you have uh
sound artists
we have it all and it was one of the
coolest place that this is where i felt
that
trickling down um
one ingredient i really felt is really
if if
it's about this space that we have to
make a point to create i think it's very
important
uh we often lament about the rigidity
but it is how you actually look at it
next please
and yeah we we even explore yeah the
space is flat you know and and what what
what do you do and and how do we go
about it right tabula rasa right but i
think there is beauty in this little
uh country of ours a city state an
island city state i think we are
conditioned
by by by the fact of we often say it's a
short history and if we personify it
we are like a rich little poor girl you
know if there's a description of or
personifying our country rich little
poor girl in that sense and and it is
this
paradox that that that um a practice any
practice that practice in singapore will
understand that
um
there is a legality of the of the the
rule of law that is strong which we
operate in
there is also the stirrer you know
aspect that we often the men say how
come we come can't be a bit more daring
and and things like that but of course
the scene have changed dramatically we
are more confident the space is not flat
anymore uh which are happy i mean based
on
um the trajectory that we have been so
far thanks
and the subsequent side is not about
just about the work that i do but it's
just a sampling about we are conditioned
uh by the fact that because of of the
construct of this country this country
as whether you call it a a garden city
city in a garden and so and and and the
fact that uh it's more known as a
business city and as an overachiever in
this part of the
the the
the region itself um
we need to be proud and and this this
yog i think in terms of uh the youth
olympics uh we were on the xenographer
um in some of the works you can see that
uh um
there is this whole tie up to the whole
ideology of
of being here practicing here we need to
be
able
to understand the narrative i think the
operative here is really we whether it's
urbanism
whether it is about an accidentalist
question about um
what is a singapore design uh what is
singapore as a place um i think it's
important it's not just an architectural
question i think
it lies in especially acutely
uh all of us and when i mean where we
are in this pandemic as we go into the
endemic
um it has reinforced a collective memory
and i think hosting
and um
a project like this right um of course
it's a pride for singapore because the
stage is in singapore but the show is to
the world and i think that is what the
last two speakers i mean uh gabriel uh
um have shown and and i'm really really
happy that this has been
been the case and i think it's about how
how we can practice it with uh
with with with the
kind of um
of of where we come from you know how
much material you know do we actually
derive when we do the work as you can
see from
um
some of these next i'll just quickly go
by and of course um when i talk about
about some of the trajectory as i move
on um they are important chapters to
buy same time i mean relevance as a
relevant to the studio in terms of how
it survived
this was a project of course close to my
heart substation we all know
it's like it has been
it is close and um
this project um
uh it was a 20th anniversary and and and
i guess um when i say relevance right i
felt that
as a practice in singapore or it is
important and be proud in in some ways
that we we are always inspired by by the
condition of where we live and also the
narrative here as a first
contemporary art
institution in singapore it was iraq i
mean it was built um uh um um by in in
uh kopalkun is is is the theater donaire
that that that have actually bring this
it has brought along all new generation
of artists and and and and all the
creative it was the place at that time
and i guess the relevance have lost and
and it has to evolve it is just like the
night and day it is a project so in
as a studio practice i guess uh it is
important to know the narrative what is
our narrative uh in when we respond to a
particular work next
and so is this where you are right now
uh you can make a guess
this is bidadari
it's a 12th time
over subscribe hdb as we speak it is all
fully built
this was um a project that meant about
even the debt the date are disturbed
this was in the heightened time of 201
one five where um muket brown is uh has
been the the the the you know they try
to buddhos uh
um
buddha's uh expressway
uh across and bidadari is also one of
the big team itself i i felt that it was
important to have a stage to play to the
goals of
of to nobody
and uh this was just a a way to respond
to the loss
and one of the key thing about in the
practice i also wanted to say was again
this condition about being young tabula
rasa being small working out the space
is also about this amplification in a
practice it is important to not just
physically practice internationally but
it's also trying to grapple because our
value system is very different in terms
of where we live our worldview about
space the concept of space is kind of
different because we we are really
living in a in a very urbanistic um
densely urbanistic city itself we rarely
call ourselves uh uh uh i mean it's is
one per
eight thousand per
per square kilometer is really a dense
place to live in and how do we dealt
with
the condition of of changes so in the
practice i felt it is important next
and of course uh
uh this is of course a bit surreal of
course you mark a chapter in terms of
this is a
installation in a national gallery
um i have a twin at the late age of 47
i felt that it was important
so i guess um
as a designer as a practice uh uh
between say how do we operate
in terms of singapore i guess is to of
course understand the narrative just
like if gabriel is in in portugal he got
to understand why he's in portugal and i
think that sharing was uh was very much
opponent one for me because it kind of
relates in terms of in terms of a craft
um what is our narrative i think to
survive is to also to understand where
we come from next
and of course a bicentennial
we
i felt cheated when i was told to do
this project um i i was a convert i
didn't know singapore history is 500
years
dated to 14th century
um this was one of uh i mean this was a
bicentennial uh pathfinder uh it was um
a kind of installation structure so same
thing there were
i think along the course of of of of
this studio
um the formative aspect about what does
it mean to to survive perhaps it's also
a
subtext to say
who are you
what is meant to be
a singaporean
a practicing in today's world
in singapore perhaps next
and and
this is just one of the installation
word that that's new chat if it is the
last day on this earth what would you
bring back with you thanks
uh next uh this is in ballet tokyo and
and of course uh last but not least
there was also the traveling show where
where there was a
newfound confidence uh a traveling show
that went to london beijing new york uh
which we kind of showcase over 97 are
creative um it was an important seminar
work because this is where we are in
terms of
how
local singaporeans have uh have have
able to go far and wide the last three
slide next
is of course as architectural
i just want to just say quickly
next
this is jacob ballas and this is in
jurong lake next
of course this lamb villa i just want to
say that
all these work
are plugged into of course a newer
narrative about what is meant to be
living in in in the city of course the
narrative here is a city in the garden
and and and and what really
um as a summary to what
is is is is that relevance
uh as we as we talk about the the
the kind of practice that we want
yeah with that thank you very much
thank you so much randy so last but not
least let us become bun young co-founder
of ecoa architects on screen please
uh good evening everyone it's really
nice to
have you guys spend time in this podcast
so when i met kelly and she invited me
to join in
this collaborative effort
uh one theme that she reminded us was
how us designers
never got this management training right
in school also focus on this studio
effect
how to focus on our creative craft
and uh my god i mean one big chunk of
being able to even do our craft is how
do you make your business and
pay the rent pay yourself pay people to
work for you
and that's something that uh
i would like to touch on briefly and
maybe there'll be more questions later
so with that i'll start a short slide
show and talk you through
and share how we started
right so
as always you know um we started in 1995
so we are pretty old firm and we are i'm
tough
but fourth gen as we call it
uh and as always the people you work
with right the partners choose is an
important
uh and sometimes a bit of a love
withdrawal whether your partners work
out or not and we've survived together
for you know 20 over years in practice
and the reality is it's never the same
right
it's uh you know even yourself changes
with time your partners and the way it's
saying will change and that adaptability
is something to do with just managing
communications
with your peers with your team with your
staff
and that's something that's an important
idea to think about
uh what's interesting is that i didn't
start having an affiliate i wanted to be
a travel journalist i wanted to be a
doctor before i switched to architecture
so
in some ways you know architects tend to
be
dabbling in many things and i think if
you have many interests
i think it's good for for what we do
um this is our studio so
i'm sad to say we grew very large at one
point and we're down to about
60 people now and we've got a few
offices one in singapore bangkok
shanghai
and and i'll share with you
the pros and cons of growing the team
and so on and managing it so we have
nice work space now everybody likes we
have a lot of parties here
so the the physical setting for a studio
and the
as a place for social interaction is
very important so when we build our new
studios
half the time is actually interaction
at work but also socially
kind of a glue that gets get us all
disgusting and thinking so we have a lot
of parties there and
really our staff grew and shrunk
and it's it's one of the key part in how
we manage the practice right because
stuffing is forever very expensive very
difficult to deal with but uh it's part
and parcel of
the foundation of what projects we do
the larger ones especially
i mean this is
huge uh we just finished a couple of
very large tall
[Music]
things take what four five six years so
to do this on projects right you have to
hire people you have to make sure that
we're able to keep the project going for
five six years
now can you imagine when you get a job
and you get a fee
you try to keep it competitive
right
and you've got inflation that runs for
four to five years you never think of
that right
uh and very often towards the end they
don't pay you on time inflation goes up
the cost of employment goes up
you are losing money right so this is
one of the things that uh over time you
really learn how to deal with some of
these uh nuts and bolts of uh
of running the
business of design
of course we do large things but
my love is still going back to small
things you know we do homes we do
private houses we do residential
projects
so
we do very modernist urban
residences
these require
time again right you know this thing
takes two and a half years
uh
so initially you think that you can hire
more people
and then have them do the work
no i mean when it when the client pays
you a good fee he wants your time
you know weekday weekends right so
there's no end to it if you're traveling
they get upset so managing
expectation
uh to be able to deliver this project
it's in itself a
little mind field to uh to have to
navigate we do projects in quite a lot
of uh
the other parts of the world
uh we do quite a lot of projects in the
mountains and uh by the sea
so these projects are quite unusual
right because we deal with the
government we build a ski resort we
build a visitor center
it requires a different skill set that a
lot of our staff never even deal with
terrain maps for example
uh half the time we are hand sketching
to get something
done right
so again the skill set of people we have
in the team
how we deal with clients you know you
can't just apply a singaporean
outlook to doing some of these projects
you have to be fairly international and
local all at the same time
so this would be a kind of a medium
project
then we do a lot of these projects um
in maldives indonesia and bali
where we do whole island you know and
and these are projects
four to five years we work with
operators we work with all sorts of
difficult constructional situations
uh and in itself managing that process
is quite an interesting um and it's
almost very rewarding uh kind of journey
right so in this project which is in the
um
south china sea you get there by
seaplane
uh in this project we built everything
from bamboo so even though what urbanist
and so on in certain contexts
in this case we chose to
have every bit of a structure built up
bamboo we had it farmed and you know we
bought farm bamboo
there's no engineer who can submit it so
we went to engineer in bandung to build
a mock-up
and figure out how to get bamboo to work
in
sort of hurricane wins right because you
have your monsoons coming in so it has
to perform it wasn't just a nice little
beautiful thing but it has to weather
the storms coming in as well
again a project like this is both modern
and traditional it was built by hand
and it means that
our team's skill set that needed to
design and draw this means that we have
to hand draw and hand sketch more than
we do a cat drawing for example because
it is down to a guy a woodworker sawing
and chiseling
on side you know and the wood is
whatever you can find for example
uh
it this was actually mocked up the
structure was so novel and the engineer
wanted to have a full mock-up done in uh
of the university ground so we put out a
full mock-up and dismantle it and reuse
it and then obviously when you put up a
full mock-up from a hand walk-up to full
mock-up it required a lot of
modification and
on-site adjustments to make it work
and in the end it was put up very
quickly because of this process right so
this is very left field for us for me as
well in the sense that uh
you know it's a beautiful craft project
right or gcp or something else or
something to modern right this
combination of craft and geometry uh
very difficult side terrain and the
limits of executing it by
teams of people who are used to traits
that they are used to they can't simply
make something that you draw on a
computer
and this our work takes us into craft
right so uh when they needed
the lamps done
i just sketched it
a village in java made a mock-up we
approved it and then a few months later
it is put up you know so this is the
art part of this type of project and
this is actually very satisfying in some
ways i find that over time i gravitate
back to these new type of projects where
it brings new ground for me for us you
know and it brings a lot of
enjoyment to the team even though it is
not easy it's not conventional anymore
so i'm going to share the really
underpinning
this whole thing
you know the things you saw what we do
and how we grew from two persons in a
gayland basement to our practice size
now
is management
that we never learn in school and it's
something you learn along the way and
you make a lot of mistakes you lose
money
in the earlier years
and uh all these translate into a few
things that i think every young designer
really ought to pay some attention to
and try to learn from mentor if possible
right
um and they translate into
many overlapping
things right
how do you get a job and the client who
comes in how do you negotiate for the
right feed you know that will pay
uh how do you collect money in time so
that your cash flow comes in monthly
that's enough to pay people
how do you project cash flow
your people then has to execute the
design with the man hours allocated
and the design that has a satisfied
client so this whole
overlapping circular
confusing diagram
is something that uh
differs from practical practice it
differs from
people's uh uh
kind of a way of organizing themselves
but in it
a few pillars never change right
uh and i think the first one is really
communication and design in a sense that
it is through your ability to
uh
have a fundamental design
love and signature that people then come
to you number one right then you when
you deal with clients
your your skill in communication it's
not simply getting the job but actually
communicating design to clients and to
your audience
i am afraid to say that
very often uh loads of people are unable
to communicate design effectively you
think it's just about design but it's
not you know it is about uh the business
idea of the design right if you do a
chair or a house or a building
uh a client have got their own agenda
you know it's gonna be nice but it'll be
affordable it has to work and i think
that's something that uh uh we as
designers really have to be very sharp
on on understand vacancy
uh and then navigating that
and getting that
fee contract in and for you to pay for
time
is something that i think we all must
learn faster than later you know when
we're very uh young we think oh god you
know would you do a design job well
people will love us and your peers
it just doesn't happen people just hate
to pay money right it's hard to get
money out of people's hands and see so i
think being very blunt
in negotiating contracts and just
knowing what you're worth okay but
someone paying for your time not doing a
free job right it's a fundamental thing
you must start on day one if you don't
you find that you're always trying to
please everybody and i think that's um
something that we have to wean ourselves
away from as soon as possible right
because if you have the attitude and the
world is good people will pay for that
time and that is going to pay for you to
grow
to to be able to uh
start the office and the infrastructure
properly to then do good work and for
you to grow to a size where you're happy
to to do your type of craft wealthy um
yeah so so i think uh in my mind these
few key things about management that we
learn
is something that we learn the hard way
and i very often will try to impart this
to young people i meet to my staff to
young people who join us as interns
you know our office grew to 100 plus at
one point uh it was not nice i would
share with you that growing for a size
uh the size just because of more work is
not the way to go right uh covet has
taught me to
be very productive
the people we have now are
very focused
and and they don't move around too much
they do things that were paid for on
time
when guys don't play we just stop the
work and we just don't do it right and
over time we realize that you get some
respect that way they pay people who
chase more right and i find that now
we're in a happier sport where i do my
work happily um you know kind of respect
us you get paid on time or more on time
than in the past right
um and there's a message i want to sort
of share with with the younger designers
who are established or starting out that
uh pay attention to this concept of
man hours right so i'll share with you
how we generate a fee proposal
it is always
cost of our time right people you hire
but you try to pay a better salary to
yourself for example you have to be very
smart about what it takes to do that
work and how many hours and hours
translate into a dollar
and then that is added up to become the
fee
uh it also means that you have to be
very efficient in the design process
it's so damn competitive i would say
that in the 90s right our architectural
fee
is at least 30 40
higher than it is now right i would say
that
generally speaking it is far more
competitive out there to
to bid for a job you know uh compared to
15 years ago
the work is harder to do kind of more
demanding authorities are more difficult
uh so if you're not careful with process
uh you will find that you cannot sustain
your work and if you can't sustain your
work you can't do what you love which is
the design yeah so my simple message is
really
value your craft and your time but try
to pay attention to the business side of
it which is actually managing clients
managing
the finances
because all that feeds into creating a
sustainable platform for you to do what
you love to do which is to design and to
produce nice work
right thank you that's my little short
uh
presentation
thank you so much bunyan we would now
like to invite all the speakers to join
us on screen for the q a segment we are
running a little bit behind on time but
we will be extending the session to
address some of the many questions you
guys have already posted so do continue
tuning in if you can so kelly over to
you yeah thank you felicia well thanks
boone i was also taking a lesson
[Laughter]
i think you know as a small studio
sometimes we always see like when we
talk about feet always when i say i say
you know the asian thing but uh yeah
really all right you know sometimes
these kind of things have to be blunt
and we deserve to be late for the work
we do
so uh anyway we actually have quite many
uh
here i'm going to uh post to uh
you guys uh
some of the questions asked here
okay so to the panelists of speakers uh
to the panel of speakers
uh her question here is what are some
challenges you guys face
when uh when you you were expanding
one man show here
exclamation mark so someone is asking a
question
uh maybe we uh shall we start with uh
maybe
think tank
small studios
uh okay because yeah i i know that the
question is from a one-man show i think
i'm quite lucky that uh i actually have
a very good co-founder here like
so
uh yeah i think initially when we
started a small studio of course the uh
doing furniture where two people is like
you need we need a lot of hands uh to
help uh it could be very operational uh
but also operational people might not be
the talent they need
but then yes you just need all the help
you can get so i think in the beginning
we were relying more on just
uh
possible yeah interns and uh i mean
basically like part-time people as well
but we found that uh it's actually
when we actually found the right tellers
then that was when the company started
we were able to delegate and
grow the company even better so i really
firmly believe that finding the right
key
members and the right teammates actually
helps to bring the studio up to where we
are today
uh how about gabriel do you want to
share your challenges
uh
yeah i mean
as you know i was i was part of this
group out of stock design for many years
for like almost 10 years so we were
always four people working together
uh
with yeah we had some full-time staff as
well and some interns so
when we decided to
go our individual practice way like in
2016 i was
basically back to my own uh just myself
alone
in the office and
[Music]
we
we basically had to start all over again
and um
yeah me working with uh
some students that came on internships
and taking whatever projects that we
could get i mean people don't know this
but maybe i spoke to kelly my first
project when i when i restarted my own
studio was like a vietnamese nail spa
and indian sari shop
that was never built because they didn't
have budget to build my designs uh but
at least thankfully i got paid for the
hours that i spent on it it was aborted
halfway and at the point i was thinking
like okay maybe i should just close shop
really you know because it's like spend
so much time on two projects i bought it
halfway never built uh the client was
happy to just
uh pay me whatever hours to terminate um
but eventually i mean things got better
after i would say one year or 18 months
and
all clients came back and new clients
came and
uh it was also partly due to people who
believe like you know people who still
willing to come on internships even
though we are no longer out of stock
design it's just gerotan
but people still want to come on
sorry
when they come for internships
yeah exactly
sorry the other partners have uh
are not here but uh yeah but i mean i
still keep a good relationship with the
people who
who came on the early days you know
coming from germany or france or belgium
to intern when i'm just just me in the
studio and then
it's also not easy for for for these
young kids yeah
yeah so guys i mean the full story of
how gabriel um you know grew as a slur
actually it's on the podcast studio sml
so please go to the spotify and listen
to his food story
and randy also actually shared on his
interview that when he first started he
had to measure water tanks on the
rooftops
to just you know get by and put bread on
the table uh randy you want to share how
you break through that and uh got your
got your first
project
yeah uh yeah it's true i i really uh it
was a three-day work um 500 dollars um
that was
1999. um
i guess um the question for us is i mean
for us is that when do we expand right
do we have enough uh i mean the the job
come first then we we employ people or
not so so i think my trajectory here is
actually
most of my artists are friends
and they actually recommend
started to recommend
clients
so it's actually from the artist side
that i
i start to grow because it can be a
simple thing as the artists themselves
who say you know what rather i got this
great idea i want this thing to be
floating in the air without lakes and
without any support
and
there you go it become a commission for
me to kind of help them out to build the
things
so from there it kind of grew um of
course you
the same trajectory you you you
you you do design work from um
mostly id first
and then uh from there you you kind of
um
of of grow with um not with permanent
stuff of course uh there were the intern
and of course i must
uh um mention this i mean you have just
mentioned penguin b he was very nice to
give me a table
uh in his office for me to begin my
practice also um i must say that uh
there is
uh
the purge that there is a patronage um
uh which uh mr tank had been was a very
instrumental person i mean he is
architect of course like you have
mentioned
uh who given me a net card because right
now to where do you operate from paying
rent uh is an issue let alone to employ
one so you just need a space and then i
guess uh by
by that process of of of that journey
you you yeah you you just grow up yeah
in in that way yeah thanks a boon i
remember the first time i met you was
actually in kelvin's basement at the
house in gala
so how did you guys uh
have a turning point and break out of
the basement and grow into the the firm
that you are today which is uh 70 or 80
people strong in the region
right so uh yes you remember that very
well so gay lump basement was uh two two
point one meter hit route but it's
terrible becca
i think you you're watching every dime
right uh uh so your free rental
uh you you lease everything so you don't
buy you know you work with interns
everything to make sure that that you
survive through that period
and really i think what happens is that
when you do something
nicely and well
and get it completed it leads to the
next thing right you know it's like our
type of work is always by referral or
when someone's pleased with your work
and so on you get referred
i think it's really a step at a time
and i think you get a point of uh
of kind of a lead right where suddenly
there's enough work to hire the next
person and the next person uh and that's
only what jumping and doing something
else you're looking at working out what
cash flow you have to pay start right
and then how to get the next client in
so it's it's a really exciting journey
and and uh i think it starts off
one small step at a time
okay i think uh i think that happens to
to most design studios uh kind of
organic growth right so slow and steady
yeah so i i think i want to move on
quickly to the next question um because
there actually quite a lot here
um okay so this question was uh actually
directed to bunyan since since we're
with you now
uh so ks say earning less is happening
to the advertising industry also how to
pay designers
uh yeah so you know
we
we are always crouching about it right
because really i think not not just
advertise the creative feel
seem to be very undervalued you know but
i think it's also part of
a changing pattern right
where in advertising now people don't do
billboards they don't use paper print
everything is online so this big
transition of of the whole industry
right
uh
in architecture as well
even though there's more technology
there's more compliance right so at some
point we have to figure out how to
find the productive time to produce work
nicely
that is why i do a lot of my work
outside just to satisfy my creative
kind of needs right because if i only
practice in singapore i think it's very
tough it's it's a very powerful world
especially at our type of size right
you know the the cost of doing business
in singapore it's extremely expensive
i'll share something with you we do a
lot of hotels right
and we obviously usually compete with
someone from barcelona or from paris or
london or uk or u.s
for a particular job overseas we're
often told that our fee is the highest
right and this is us working out man
hours very carefully
and the fact is that we're being priced
out of the market
by
singapore right singapore is damn
expensive
rental
then um hiring locals and everything so
i don't know man i don't know what the
magic bullet is but
you have really had to watch
cost that is why i have my offices now
in bangkok
uh starting one in europe where it's a
very low cost base i would say that
those places is half my cost here so i'm
able to deliver on a project and charge
half the man over time so that's
something that may have to happen it may
be through collaboration so you do the
front and design you collab with
somebody else from somewhere else who's
able to help to see through a project at
a much lower cost
yeah so those are the realities on the
ground and it's
it is
sad but that's the reality and you just
find a way to get past that and survive
thanks for the answer okay the next
question is uh uh
to all the speakers thank you for
sharing do you feel that a physical
studio space is really needed for
growing okay it's versus building a
community as randy mentioned
okay so maybe randy you want to take the
question um
[Music]
it
you know it's not the physicality i i
want to say that uh
the answer here is that it's really um
[Music]
a meeting point you know i i felt that
uh of course you can operate from homes
as well but the reference that i'm
trying to say here is
um
doing a practice in singapore can be
quite lonely like because uh
i mean um that there's always this as i
mentioned um we are also busy we hardly
uh need time to have a discourse okay
it's very important you meet up it
doesn't need to be your your fellow
architects why men is a space that you
you meet up and you can discuss um
possibility so um it is important that
there is that meeting and you can see a
lot of the
the the modernist art movement i mean um
it arises out from a collective you see
so that the emphasizing part i wanted to
say is
uh
the
the design studio the starting out is
that you do not see yourself as uh
as just one
one person in the studio but i think you
land strength you you you you aspire you
look at you what your peer uh and and
and see the energy because at the end of
the day it is about this energy that you
need to rally from the community hence
the space here is
physical as much as it's also
a mental honor yeah
on that note gabriel maybe i ask you
because you physically
moved from singapore to uh to portugal
um so
do you think that the the idea of
physicality has an effect or impact on
you as a designer
um
for me not so much but i think my
my studio has kind of gotten used to
to this that i am
working remotely uh
with them but i'm super active on
whatsapp you know be day or night or
midnight or three in the morning so it's
not so good for my health but then i try
to keep up with whatever's going on in
the studio as much as possible and there
are three of them in the singapore
office
maybe expanding to fosso that the main
thing is that they have a good rapport
and they all like each other they work
well together and then i operate as a
kind of satellite
um
and uh
i i when i see new things in in
different parts of
wherever i am i try to share with them
so that they also i mean i think with
the lockdown is very difficult as well
because people want to travel but they
they're not able to so
i'm thankful that i still am able to go
to milan fair and things like that and i
try to share as much as i can with my
office
um and and to try to keep in constant
contact so but in the beginning it was
tough and it was a little bit difficult
to keep people happy but i think after
one year now it's it's quite we've
gotten used to it yeah okay and and to
jessica and pamela on the this idea of
physical space you guys run a retail
shop so
uh
conventionally you know for retail the
physical space is very important but now
you know with covet and also the 21st
century is really everything
what what's your what's your take on
physical space versus online for retail
i think for us actually the retail space
is a very important space because we
don't run it like a
like just a short wedding it is to
create that whole philosophy and
environment where people step in and
feel like this is their home i think
like i mean because like our designs are
really just really about the experience
and the stories it is actually kind of
important for us
uh having said that i think all our
retail shops are previously
uh we had one reference hotel and then
we have one the first one that we opened
was beachwood
uh we are actually closing these stores
because they're in the city center and i
think because of kobe
we find that it no longer makes sense to
pay the rents
for
a city center kind of space but we also
find that it is important so because
people want to come down and touch and
feel and experience i think also part of
the joy of our customers is also like
speaking with our retail staff speaking
with us to understand about the story i
think that people don't buy our products
because of like price points or whatever
person i think it's really about the
interaction there and i think it is
important so we have actually moved to a
bigger space we are in the means of
starting up opening in october
um we want to create this whole
environment it's a lot bigger than our
current stores
our current stores are about 1 000
square feet each only but we've moved to
an industrial building where the rent is
really really cheap i think you're quite
lucky
i think this is a good time also i mean
you know there are difficulties but also
at this time
there's also opportunities that come up
that might not come up during colgate
because we found a unit that uh actually
was at a very good rate and i think it
somehow just uh we felt that it meets
our needs uh but it also wasn't like a
sudden thing it wasn't like we were
forced to move in catholic because we
also already knew that
um
we needed this space we needed
to rent it's just that cold it just
forced us to move this faster and i
think in a way also
it works out well for us
so yeah i think i would think that the
physical space is important but
um i think it's growing quite
organically i think changes come along
the way and uh because we're still kind
of small we can still react fast enough
like
for example to like actually we actually
terminated uh the lease for office
earlier earlier to uh move into a bigger
space to cut down the costs and all that
kind of stuff so i think it all works
out
uh in the end
i think also that like you know um
there's something about synergistic
exchange with your team that you you can
get on
a virtual call and everything but it's
just different when you come together in
a physical space and i think that's
necessary from time to time i'm not
saying like you know like i guess with
this situation it's it's um
it's fine to do really try and like meet
all together but we try as much as
possible if we can to get you know get
as much physical interaction as we can
so i think to a certain extent and for
the need that we
require it is necessary
okay so i want to touch a bit on this
issue that a lot of my
friends who are who run design studios
wow they said that you know millennials
these days uh you know they they they
value you know work life balance uh no
no longer they are like our generation
where i must work
so um a lot of them you know come and go
so so the question is actually now uh
from one of the the audience here how do
you guys stack the problem of finding
and retaining talents
uh shall we start with boone
oh i know all about that yeah
well i think the reality is that you
know you see all types of people right
it is true that the younger generation
now especially from comfortable
backgrounds
don't value that long-term professional
definition of craft and their work
but you find the people who still
believe in that right and
i think in our type of work it could be
furniture with architecture
the approach of design and craft means
mentorship it means time spent on the
ground there's no shortcut right if you
dabble you'll never be good right so
these people will come and go but you
get people who
are naturally tuned to this and they
will stay so they're not they're less
and less harder to find i mean uh uh it
used to be
you can hire from all over right but now
it's so difficult you know with the ep
and all that but um
you you have to find these people and
then
in some ways uh they follow your work
too right so if you have something
that's compelling they also want to work
there because they want to learn
something
you know i can't expect people to stay
with me forever that's not realistic
right but i think people give you the
energy and time and you
they learn something good right
that is the way the world has always
operated
okay thank you uh maybe i i also pose
this question to randy who is a m
science uh firm how do you retain uh and
keep your talents
um
well um it it is uh the hardest part of
um of running a practice right now um
but i must say that uh
um it is reciprocal it's not uh i mean
it's is is it
what is important here is um
i guess to understand that the
millennial come from
come from about i mean their value
system is quite different as we all know
is about that meaning and and you can
really get it when
um the last three years uh they
interview you instead they ask what is a
csr for for for the company do we do we
do
outposts to build um
for some of great communities like that
you can really see see that so in other
words i think for me the retaining
of talents and the engagement here is uh
meaningfully right the
the office
uh will
need to have
um
the aspect of the community engagement
which we do quite a fair bit i mean we
are quite involved with the arts
community with the urban
farming movement with the conservative
movement to preserve golden mile tower i
think these are i won't call it activity
getting together but they are
believe that
what the firm actually stands for and i
think this is just
one of the few ways apart from the
remuneration as well as the job
satisfaction that they must get but
definitely communication as well as
getting that that that kind of a pad in
the back is kind of important way of
getting them engaged all the time yeah
okay thanks randy okay we uh i think we
are running out of time so uh but there
are actually a lot of questions here so
i'm just going to
uh pick
one
and then uh
for all of you to wrap up
um
okay so i i think really uh okay there's
a field that is uh repeated
what would be your advice for uh
startups uh small brands you know um
with small budget
who want to start their own studio today
because i think for for
especially boone and randy who you know
we are a little bit older um during our
time i think uh singapore the center of
living is not so high starting you know
starting out the entry barrier still not
so high i think jessica and gabriel in
their 30s is like in between but i think
in this day and age those who want to
start up in their 20s
i think the entry barrier is much higher
so what would be your last word and
advice to
the young people who want to start up
their own small studio
okay i'll shoot first yeah
um you're right so this issue of a very
high cost of entry means that
you really might
plan to do
uh
it could be a design service it could be
a product but it must be viable and you
must do some napkin calculations there
will be a cafe a restaurant same thing
right you must work out costs and income
coming in
and then you're worth you know whether
you're good enough to attract the work
that's going to keep you going so you
might be very honest with yourself and
you will know when the moment it's right
you know that ah this guy's going to pay
me this to
to commission me to do this work so i
think you have to be quite realistic and
don't dream might be very
clear about the facts
but there's always risk you ultimately
still must take that leap off the edge
of the cliff and take a risk
and do something like this if you really
dream about it thank you
thanks uh randy what's your advice
well um
don't hurry i i believe that uh it's
important that uh
one really see
work in a in a practice understand the
practice and then here comes the
confidence and belief but very important
is that of course uh that big jump to
start a firm uh i guess is is a rare
personal one uh the conviction therefore
is really
how you could tap on uh already known
knowledge
from your peer or or someone's here
thank you
okay thanks uh gabriel your advice
um
i mean as much as possible i tried to do
everything myself at the beginning to be
honest uh until it came to a point where
i realized i needed other skill sets and
other
um but once once
i mean i would say to identify
weaknesses or strengths that you want
or weaknesses of yourself and strength
that you need to complement yourself and
then either you if you cannot afford the
higher you get in a partner that is the
easiest
way to
um
yeah to grow as a studio you get in
partners that complement your skill sets
and bring something that you you do not
offer
that's good advice uh how about jessica
and emma do you want to wrap up the
session with your advice to people who
want to start up their own studio
um i think be open-minded always be
willing to
learn from people
ask questions from people who have gone
before
um
and
i think also not be prideful like be
really open to work
to work with anything that kind of comes
at you first i think at the start you
know you have nothing
at all right so like whatever comes at
you like just be open-minded and you
know and not prideful and just like okay
just try it out gain some experience and
then from there start to build your
identity and like you know then you can
ask for more in in future
um yeah yeah i think the part about
being uh
not being priced is quite important i
think it's just me genuine i think that
if you really want to grow you
definitely need to build all these
relationships and you really never know
like i think people that have met right
i think
uh
i was a young
student and i visited like kente and and
that was the first time i actually met
kelly i think you know you never know at
that point of time you know you you meet
this person and after that like i mean i
think kevin has become kind of like also
a mentor for us
you know each interaction here right
always counts for something i think at
the end and like i think it's fun to
just generate and you
yeah are willing to learn i think i
think you have to get
that right from the beginning yeah
and yeah oris randy we need to start
another nine day yes it's true
incubation
and uh thank you guys thank you so much
we uh i think we had a very good session
today uh thank you for your time and
thank you for uh being my first uh
people for studio xml
so i also want to thank all the audience
today who are time off to uh to listen
to our talk and to share with us um to
the many questions that we still
couldn't answer i think uh we will
we have a platform to answer you
privately we'll also send the individual
questions to the panelists
um so yes to actually listen to their
food stories please log on to our
website
studio sml.net and also we have actually
asked
on spotify so you just go to spotify and
search for xml and you can listen to all
the speakers today and their in-depth
stories
and
there is also an exhibition at national
design
center right now which uh which is
called abstract creatures
featuring the the panelists today
actually so
please visit